ein möglicher NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine
zu diesem Thema begrüße ich bei uns im
moor-studio die Leiterin der
Forschungsgruppe Sicherheitspolitik der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
Claudia major schönen guten Morgen guten
Morgen Frau major eigentlich sind sich
ja alle dass ein NATO-Beitritt der
Ukraine während des Krieges nicht
denkbar ist aber mal für die Zeit danach
gesprochen und generell gefragt was
spricht für einen Beitritt der Ukraine
zur NATO und was spreche dagegen
aus Sicht der Ukraine ist natürlich so
ein Beitritt notwendig um die Sicherheit
des Landes zu gewährleisten also um
sicherzustellen dass nicht der nächste
Krieg nach einem möglichen
friedensschuss sofort wieder losgeht die
Nato hat sich für ihre Mitglieder als
Lebensversicherung bewährt also es
schützt Sie und diesen Schutz wie die
Ukraine haben das zeigt dieser Krieg
noch mal ganz toll aber was wichtig ist
dass auch ein Beitritt der Ukraine zur
NATO in einer sehr langfristigen
Perspektive auch aus Sicht der
NATO-Staaten sinnvoll ist denn eine
Ukraine die von Russland besetzt oder
erobert ist und ein Russland dass die
Lehre gezogen hat dass es mit Krieg
führen seine Ziele erreichen kann das
ist kein sicheres und stabiles Europa
das heißt deshalb ist eine stabile
Ukraine geschützt in der NATO auch in
unserem eigenen Sicherheitsinteresse der
zu kommt auch noch dass es darum geht
den Wiederaufbau abzusichern das heißt
ein sicheren Rahmen für den
wirtschaftlichen Wiederaufbau zu sichern
auch ein möglichen langfristigen
EU-Beitritt abzusichern das heißt wir
müssen ganz klar sagen dass ein
langfristiger NATO Beitritt nicht nur im
Interesse der Ukraine ist sondern in
unserem ureigenen Sicherheitsinteresse
nun hofft die Ukraine auf ein deutliches
Signal beim Nato-Gipfel im Juli die
osteuropäischen Länder sind für einen
schnellen Zeitplan die USA und
Deutschland sind dann noch zögerlich was
hat die Ukraine jetzt bezüglich dieses
Gipfels und einer möglichen
Vorentscheidung dazu erwarten das
versuchen gerade die NATO-Außenminister
in Oslo ein bisschen fest zu räumen das
vor genau der Gipfel findet im Juli in
Vilnius statt ich glaube was wichtig ist
dass es eine klare Roadmap also einen
klaren Plan gibt es gibt die Zusage die
Frage ist wie füllt man diese Zeit
zwischen jetzt und einer möglichen eine
möglichen Beitritt der in sehr weiter
Ferne liegt und da muss man überlegen
wie man diesen diese diesen Prozess von
Sicherheit zu sagen bis zur Garantie das
wäre der Beitritt gefüllt also über
bilaterale Zusagen über eine stärkere
Anbindung an die Nato und dass sie
beispielsweise wie Finnland und Schweden
im Rahmen des Beitrittsprozesses an den
Sitzungen schon teilnehmen können dass
sie Sitzungen teilweise auch mit
einberufen können das ist dass sie
herangeführt werden an die NATO
und an die Übungen also man kann sie und
man sollte sie mit klaren Schritten so
nah wie möglich ran führen aber auch
klar machen dass die ultimative
Lebensversicherung Artikel 5 nur für
Mitglieder zählt sprechen wir über die
Drohnenangriffe vorgestern auf Moskau
ein präsidentenberater des Präsidenten
selensky hat gestern gesagt die Ukraine
habe damit nicht direkt etwas zu tun hat
damit natürlich Platz gelassen für
Spekulation wie schätzen Sie das ein hat
die Ukraine Moskau mit Drohnen
angegriffen wir wissen es nicht die
Ukraine hat das dementiert wir müssen
uns natürlich fragen wie es möglich ist
ohne das Wissen der Ukraine so eine
große Anzahl von Drohnen herzustellen zu
bewaffnen und loszuschicken aber wir
wissen es nicht was aber mir noch mal
wichtig ist ist zu sagen dass die
Ukraine nach der vn-karte
Selbstverteidigungsrecht Artikel 51 das
Recht hat sich gegen Russland zu
verteidigen und damit auch Ziele in
Russland anzugreifen es gibt zwei
Elemente die dabei das Begrenzen das
eine ist das muss durchschnittsmäßig
sein und das humanitäre Völkerrecht gilt
das heißt Sie dürfen keine zivilen Ziele
angreifen das heißt Ziele strategische
Ziele wie im letzten Jahr die
bomberplätze in Engels die sind durch
die vn-karte gedeckt aber keine zivilen
Ziele völkerrechtlich gedeckt sagen sie
politisch sieht der Westen oder Teile
des Westens das aber kritisch die USA
haben sich sofort gemeldet und haben
gesagt sie möchten eigentlich nicht dass
die Ukraine Ziele auf russischem
Territorium angreifen genau ich glaube
das wirklich das wichtige wichtige
Element dabei ist es geht um keine
Angriffe auf Städte wie Moskau oder
zivile Ziele weil das ja den riesen
großen Unterschied auch im Respekt des
Völkerrechts macht und die USA und auch
Deutschland haben immer gesagt sie
sollen diese Waffen sind für die
Verteidigung der Ukraine dass sie ihr
eigenes Gebiet und ich betonen dass ihre
Bevölkerung ihre Menschen die dort leben
ja dass sie die befreien können aber
nicht gegen Russland in Russland und das
ist glaube ich der wichtige Unterschied
zu Befreiung ja und auch so Vorbereitung
deswegen wie gesagt Angriffe auf
Flugplätze oder
Kommandozentralen sind gedeckt aber
nicht gegen Russland in Russland wie
schätzen Sie das ein welchen Effekt
haben diese Drohnenangriffe es waren ja
nicht die ersten Drohnen Angriffe auf
russischem Gebiet aber die ersten in
Moskau also das russische Militär und
die Luftabwehr bloßgestellt die
Bevölkerung in Moskau verunsichert was
bedeutet das jetzt für den Kriegsverlauf
und was bedeutet das für die russische
Seite
momentan die sind hatten diese Angriffe
mehr psychologische Effekte zu zeigen
dass der Krieg in Russland ankommt das
Russland verwundbar ist und dass diese
Geschichte vom siegreichen Russland in
der Ukraine nicht stimmt weil sie nicht
mehr in der Lage sind ihr hinterlassen
militärisch macht das noch kein so
großen Unterschied und wir müssen auch
sagen dass ein Ereignis alleine noch
nicht zu einem Umdenken in Moskau führt
also es ist so eine Kette von mehreren
Ereignissen die dazu führen könnten dass
auch die russische Regime Sicherheit und
so ein bisschen in Frage gestellt wird
aber dieses eine Ereignis alleine wird
dann nicht groß werden
leider Einschätzungen der
Sicherheitsexpertin Claudio Major von
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
vielen Dank dass Sie heute morgen da